[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right
and we are live more cognito here i love
podcasts
and gentlemen we have in the realm of
past quest today i am creative director
for the rose guidelines jin sounds
speaking
nice
nice to
so really quick before we get into it
it's going to get a little back story
now you guys officially kickstarter and
then the timer
there's full disclosure and um i wanted
to say like i think we played on xbox
early access right
it's actually a month away it's the 13th
october 30th october uh-huh okay so it's
only a month away yeah and for the xbox
we are trying to we're we're working
hard on it right now yes probably early
next year thank you for trying to find
that because i've always wanted to know
a lot of people
so let's get ready all right um
this is the chapter four of the game
we're just gonna throw at you
so
if you begin the better this is the
first chapter we introduce the monster
oh okay so let's click on the beginning
the better okay
you're gonna play though you want me to
play yeah
okay so this is the monster
and this monster they have a different
mechanics from human beings
and we introduce the weak points
so
you have attacked with a certain
weapons
or certain point of the entire yeah so
you will see what i'm talking about
right what i remember from playing the
um demo it was kind of like long
distance
short and then there was also like a
heavy one to almost break shield and
stuff like that but you you showed me
because
it's been a while since i played and
this is actually voice acting yes so we
have a voiceover
on better conversations and main stories
and soft
all right so um this is the uh you know
how they are how they are going to
affect me it's a traditional grid style
i'm just gonna prepare
so
you see
you know that the weak point this is
where you want to hit with the fish and
this is where you want to hit with the
magic
but then it changes over the top
[Music]
i mean i guess my question for you was
one thing that i really respect about
those idols is that
you have the the character classes but
they was kind of like paper scissors
rock
where one style would counter the other
style you know what inspired that comic
but i think it's a very unique thing
especially for long distance characters
they use arrows and things that nature
it's beneficial for them to stay in the
back
and that's what i know about the thought
process the inspiration
well um
we do have a russian and like uh the
sword is against the boot against the uh
rather armor
and x is good against the plated armor
and the spear and the arrows the archers
are against the crows yes so um we
do have this triangle
i love this tutorial this really helped
me in the mix yeah actually this is
based on our feedback from the users
like you like people were asking me to
put that on i i was a champion yeah and
i was like yeah this is great because
now the player gets to see your face if
you're fighting a heavily armored
character these are heavy weapons and
and that is really cool especially with
the how long distant stuff is done so
i'm gonna attack magic on this big time
okay
so it's gonna do the chain here if you
continue doing the attacking the weak
point it's gonna give you extra damage
another thing that i thought was unique
was i don't know if it's still retained
but
when you attack the enemy can attack
still is that something that's still in
the game where the monsters if they are
hit by the hit on a weak point they
won't attack you
but then the human beings will attack
you
[Applause]
as long as they can attack yeah i mean
if they're out of range they will not be
attacked which is why i used to use my
archers on certain ones because i knew
they were too far to attack
this is good
let's go so you can see that he's not
hard to attack again
another thing that i love about eidolon
so far was just like
the the cinematic nature of the battles
like you see like you're going into it
and i think this is really cool as a fan
of trend based i think what would get
more people into the genre is what you
guys are doing the stylistic approach
showing the combat and then earlier
stages i see like the background of
people fighting the city you know is
that something that you're oh no that's
good yeah it gives the sense of war are
you really in a battlefield this is
where we um actually had a lot of
discussions because it's more like a
triangle
but uh
we didn't like the idea of having the
whole army of the time right there
but so we kind of used the uh the way
the firebrand did and have a feeling of
all the armies we had the different
ideas like having a big stereo of the
character and having the
small enemies minimize
it's a big dogs man
now they are trapped
so i have time to you know manage it
and then for those who don't know
obviously i played a lot but
that looks so serious
for those who don't know i know eden is
like a main character what's the general
premise of the story for those who don't
know anything about los angeles okay the
eden is actually just a normal plane
from the small town for the rometta
and he got into trouble with the loads
of ronita and find out how productive
empire is
and enjoy the rebellion and go against
the
the more complicated stories along the
way
[Music]
and by the way we have the swap weapon
system
which costs you nothing at all
so
you can keep whatever equipment you want
to
and you can swap it so you can maximize
your strategy i respect that because
what also you did there is that you
don't lock the player into a specific
class and they could adapt on the
battlefield and the fact that most turn
base would make you lose an action point
to do that and you'll use it as part of
the fluid combat to be able to switch on
the fly
because of that mistake you may make we
added a new picture
now you can
any any point of the game
so let me let me show you let's go
so here you can go
from the beginning you can actually go
right into the beginning of the video
but you don't want to do it now we have
unlimited undos no actually not
unlimited but you can do 10 times
for the normal difficulties and as you
progress the game you will have an
increase amount
okay
now what about the higher difficulties
will that have less undues or remove the
mechanic
but you will have more if you progress
the game got you okay
number three
it's been
almost three years now
uh um two and a half years to be
one of yeah showcases i saw the game and
the cool thing also to it
with the narrative you guys also kept
that i want to know this has changed or
not seemed to have included a lot of
cinematics as far as
now how has there been a
with a fundamental change
well we wanted to make it as cinematic
as possible
but you have seen i don't know if you
have seen it but in our first demo we
had like four scenes being cinematic yes
but then we find it it's really hard to
do it yes because we're
limited resources
so um we
limited to um total number of cinematic
right it's
about 20 of us okay we made a lot though
we made a lot i was expecting only like
five percent nothing much our team did a
great job on it so we have more than
like 20 of them
internally
damage over time on fire
all from the fire here
we have the synergies on magic so if you
um
use your magic
fire magic on the food it will make it
fun and we will be on fire so if you
stay there for you know over time you're
going to get damaged
and you we have a synergies another
system that we can maximize is you
you know use a water magic
so try to
also use the ice magic to charismatic
increase the enemy so that making enemy
unable to move
definitely
a crit you get that extra you guys know
you get that nice nice
that's a new touch i didn't see that
before oh you just had it i know you
didn't i didn't see that
let's go we just added it like a month
later
[Applause]
what was some of the games that you feel
uh i know you mentioned fire emblem
before any other title that
may have inspired you before
and the other one is our previous 50
barrel of the game
our entire team is from the rest of the
world from the game
so um that was another inspiration
now another thing i wanted to ask real
quick was why are you fighting
uh
and are we getting any um bonuses from
from like side or back attacks or
actually um
i didn't like um
maybe if i
have another step to
decide
which which direction you want to put
better yeah so
i want i want more speedy battery i mean
this is already like a 30 minute battery
so um
oh
let's go
you can entirely skip it or you can also
um speed up two times
so like sometimes i get sick over
watching yeah
okay
you know like the animations you
remember
you know it because you you even thought
10 hours
you can say that that's the poor
um
and what i i love what you just did what
you just did was very subtle
because you put the arrow down there
between
right behind
this way he can't be directly attached
and you can safely pick away that's the
mechanic that i feel a lot of television
don't do
and i started to utilize that strategy
that was really cool before for that
matter we added a job control feature
where the energy cannot pass by
so we have like when you have like it's
a thing to you too when enemies stare
even if you want to get the weaker ones
right there you cannot have five right
because they're blocking right
and that total
position
damage reduction where we didn't have
that feature
we only had the increased amount of
chance
but then i thought
that chance was too low
because it's only like a 10 or something
like that it only increases to like 11
minutes
so that's
i thought that was not
you know not enough so we added we ended
the feature recently to have increased
amount of i mean reducing the damage by
one okay so if you depend yeah
what a little bit of the commitment
oh
[Music]
um
all right
she can't reach that
should we increase the damage we're
still in the top so
you're still in discussion for the
[ __ ] i can see it because what end it
is it is an advantage for the whole
character
we get a lot of feedback that
people thought like
they give me like it's not that fun
but we still believe that it is fun
because if you have a puzzling
right and it has like a chain attack
that will give you like
really if you do the
fourth chain of the attack it would give
you a little a lot of damage
[Music]
you know you may have to influence the
grace
to reward them to show them that may be
the way
that's what we're trying to do so like
uh
to give it more intention
when you do the final um chain attack
the first the first one you give it a
particular attack okay so it gets more
damaged
it's a tough one because i can
understand i can understand on both
sides from a development standpoint you
don't want to make that
class so overpowered from the from the
back end but on the other side you're
showing like
you can you know you can do something
you can do other things to try to
increase damage
oh
okay
so we have the magic where we don't have
a mana
what i intended with that is to
really like think about it you know
right i want you to think more deeply
it's magic you want to use and and fuji
bishop you don't want to just out
humanize it
did you get that
beat that yeah of the battle
and
it's good to see the game still
progressing
it looks like you guys are still making
a lot of design choices on where you
want to go you know as far as right now
you're still building well um
i know like we have a lot of features
left out like we like i wanted to put
like a new game process
out of time
we have announced the launch date and
that launch date is that launch date is
the 13th of october
business day only a month away not the
way for pc we are really like
kicking our affairs
getting out of the bus and try to
optimize the game nice that's what we
are doing right here
absolute pleasure i think it has a lot
of potential
to see this big journey i want my
console brethren i know what the pc
comes out all right my console brother
would love
i love to get their heads back right now
because the xbox i got a chance to play
there but um yeah like i said once that
happens
let us know and any of the other
information you want to let our audience
know about those i love that they may
not know already
well
now we have told you the wrong state and
the plan for that
and if the game goes well enough we're
going to have another like dlc and all
the stories that we could add for the
right you know
whichever characters are popular
i have like all the stories kind of like
synopsis or characters
and we also want to um add the features
like this the new gameplay
you got to be very
humble with the story aspects and i feel
that um there's a lot of things in the
story as far as from a cinematic
standpoint the way they're presenting
the story is really cool so i'll let you
guys reveal that
but uh i do want to give you guys credit
out there and we're looking forward to
release better
already absolutely lost eidolons
again the lords have had their eye on
this we saw that one of the console
showcases you got a chance to see the
team lucy driving the squad an absolute
pleasure man thank you so much
no problem
[Music]
welcome to the iron lord's party